[Music]
three
two one action welcome back to off the
record where we talk about whatever we
want and uh you guys are over there
we're
just now looking at you know i got
have you been to the beach i was in the
new jersey and then i
really you know how i love trash tv
i was like if we're gonna be in jersey
we gotta go to jersey shore
are things open up there there's such a
raccoon yeah it's open
yeah it's out there jersey shore
it's much cleaner than i thought it was
gonna be
because i'm not right now no one's there
that much
you know what's weird okay i think
california is much more paranoid
about the mask situation but i don't
know because the oc is different right
but california knows how to party though
but it feels like those had a pie
i think people in jersey um at least
what i experienced
it seems like mask seems optional so
there are people doing it
and there are people that aren't doing
it but i don't see the shaming happening
like i was all over princeton
you just see all kinds of different
people choosing
to or not to and if people don't have
the mass to walk by you like this or
like
if people don't have the mask on and if
they walk by they'll put the mask on
and then they'll take it off and they'll
walk away or whatever uh
but when i was at the
joisty shore almost everyone had a mask
on
on the on the pier on the pier but not
on the not on the beach
oh that makes sense though because
they're like super compacted then saw
some fans too
we're swimming and then um they go hey
are you a youtuber and i'm like kinda
and they're like i knew it jk news they
knew everything about you yeah and then
they're swimming next to me and then
we're just going under the waves
together and i said all right bye
did they ask to take a picture nah we
were in the water together
there was like a big group of dudes here
that were just swimming together
did they say with a jersey accent nah i
wish though
what would that sound like hey paulie
isn't that the guy from that
channel the the [ __ ] you know the
youtubes man
hey vinnie i think that's him bro that's
him
time yeah cool i don't know there's
gonna be more characters than that yeah
i was like destined to meet a paulie and
a guy that talks like this and all that
and um my friend's uh
client or whatever from the mushroom
farm he he would
he was on the phone with them and i i
thought i was talking to a mafia member
like there's so many guys that talk like
that oh that's tight because we're not
used to that actually no
we only understand it through the movies
and like shows we've watched
and it's always like coffee scary people
with that accent no but he was just kind
of like a
gr he was like a buyer for a grocery
store
it's probably the thinnest mask because
i can hear you perfectly oh yeah this is
i don't think this is the uh
that's the match just to be able to get
into places medical grade at all it's
just yeah this is the bare minimum mask
yeah this is yeah it's not it's not
supposed to be the safest one
yo they're beach though the sand is
weird it's kind of like
coarse and hard yeah it looks like it
would be that way
but it's soft it's it's like it's yeah
the sand pieces are bigger
it's coarse but it's it's bigger it it
seems like
but it's like super duper slow it's
weird i don't know i just kept [ __ ]
just like rocks like course and like it
doesn't feel good to walk and you can't
really like chill there
joe joe at the beach is like a little
kid he's meeting people he's like hi
okay bye he's like playing with stanley
no [ __ ] though i didn't even talk to the
people i was with that much
i literally was just i just kept i i
probably went for 30 minutes how
different the sandwich did you smoke
and then i no like that was just me and
then i covered my whole entire body half
of it in the sand and i went to sleep
and then i got up because the water came
and i went back into the water we went
to get pizzas
the water was warm it was a warm water
yeah i was shocked i was like did the
east coast man supposed to be cold and
[ __ ]
and the water was teeth i think pacific
is colder it's pretty cold
it's cold out here yeah i've never been
in the atlantic ocean
that was my first time man yeah i've
never been to florida
like miami not in the water what is uh
the florida water consider arctic still
or no it's atlantic headline i thought
it was
caribbean no it's atlantic waters it's
the atlantic ocean that goes into the
gulf
but uh yeah in my experience it seems
like uh it seems like
atlantic waters like the coast on that
side the waters are way
calmer and on the pacific side we get
like all the surfer
waves oh that's why the big surfers
don't really come from the east coast
town yeah they're all
they're on this side in hawaii and stuff
like that like the pacific ocean is just
like more rough so if you're more into
like the chill
the beach uh hangout sessions then
definitely go to the east coast
well they get hurricanes but they get
haircuts
and then it's kind of really rough yeah
it goes back to really
it's like when you when you like charge
something up like a dog and you don't
let him like run
and then he just takes off is that how
it works like a cartoon did you ever say
why i was out there
mushrooms mushrooms i think people
follow you they know what
did i ever talk about on jk news yeah
you did you said you're going to uh
jersey into a day yeah you did because
because steve was trying to
uh uh make a joke oh
okay because he thought he was trying to
say i was getting some fan [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah
fans are safe exactly fan service not
what he's trying to do so i am uh uh uh
i'm in partnership with a mushroom farm
legal mushrooms yeah that's why because
i i was i was like i don't know if i
should
say it because people really want to
hear my story
of [ __ ] a lot of fans or something
right because i just got people we're
all dying
just make one up then oh yeah [ __ ] i
[ __ ] a lot
i [ __ ] a lot it was yeah i [ __ ]
like
i [ __ ] snooki she's married no snarky
another one
smirky snark snooky yeah um
and uh now i just i i had some pizza
but we shouldn't talk about pizza and
stuff like that because of the whole
yeah but well i mean if it's pepperoni
pizza
it's pepperoni pizza cheese pizza no
it's not cheese pizza
yep pizza gate cheese pizza
means child porn pepperoni pizza means
parental porn you know
yeah what about uh chicken chicken is a
little kid right
i don't know okay that's what what came
on that in uh hillary's emails
oh they kept talking about chicken
chicken and then the one guy that [ __ ]
the one guy that was like seth green's
best friend was like he kept telling me
about this
he kept saying i love chicken i love
chicken then you later find out that i
meant like
children and then all of hillary's
things they kept bringing up we're gonna
sacrifice a chicken to
this why would they ward it like that
sacrifice a chicken so these are these
are what came out and it came up from
like
i feel like some like sources i feel
like i could trust but with online you
never
yeah that's true yeah but and with cheat
pizza they were referring to it as like
in the emails that leaked was like they
were like uh like oh
uh i want a cheese pizza for one hour or
cheese oh
i like anchovy pizza adult porn so
what's happening with all that stuff
like is
they're just like forget it i don't even
know if these things get pinned on them
like that's the difference between like
you know like
some celebrity [ __ ] comes out right and
then like you have
they stop everything quote receipts or
whatever and then you can start people
start bombarding their pages
and then almost forces them to make a
statement about it like whether
it's real or it's fake or whatever but
they do make a statement about it
with um these politicians i don't know
if people are
bombarding like others they are every
single person that's involved they're
getting bombarded to the point where
twitter steps in and says if you are
affiliated to q and on
yeah we're blocking all that [ __ ] out so
they just which they shouldn't
so hillary is john and something i don't
even know but they can just keep
posting whatever they want and like
unfazed but i feel like i still see them
in the news just doing normal [ __ ] like
are they still
working huh who's who's hillary oh yeah
they're
for sure she's a career politician man
that's
i don't know what they would do if they
didn't have that true and i
and all these things all these stories
about like you know child
pedophilia and all that [ __ ] like it's
all like conspiracy at this point
so like none of it really sticks you
know as long as it's like
making sure it doesn't yeah as long as
it's labeled that
there's gonna be people that don't
believe it or they're gonna get away
you know scotch free this [ __ ] is so
weird like i was looking at ellen
degeneres because she's on
they say she's on the list obviously
again these are there's no real hard
[ __ ] receipts so we can just go off
whatever we see and we kind of have to
connect our own dots
um and i was just looking through her
instagram because i just [ __ ] snoop
like that
and she's there's this one clip you guys
can check it out like she's still on
there she does an ig
story no not a story uh a post and she's
uh cutting her gram uh her mom's hair
and as she's cutting it she's cutting it
in the bathroom and she has like a
picture like a painting
like a painting behind her and that [ __ ]
is so [ __ ] cryptic
it's like this like it looks like a kid
drew it but it's like in
reds and browns and like burgundies and
blacks
and it's like a stick figure and it
looks like it's like a little kid body
like a stick figure
i don't like that yeah and then you see
like like organs kind of coming out of
it and it's
ellie it's weird it looks like a demonic
figure and it's not even like i would
something i have to go like
hey you're about to see this demonic
thing and it kind of biases your mind
and then when you see it you're like oh
yeah it's one of those things you just
see it and you're like
wait why does this nice ass mansion have
this well and especially
her branding right like her branding is
what is it be kind or some [ __ ] like
that like that's always been her like
things are very pleasant and happy all
the time yeah and i'm like okay you can
have your own
like art preferences and [ __ ] but it's
like it's just
there's too many coincidences for me a
piece of art with like an
innocent lens what would you be saying
it's weird it is weird like i can pull
it up but
it's [ __ ] weird like some of the
paintings that were in
john podesta's house the guy that's
being tied to the cheese
would you say sorry who is that john
podesta is that the pizza owner
the pizza parlor guy oh no he's like a
uh he's like government-related guy i
forgot exactly what it was
but his house was all weird and messed
up man
it was it was he's the one that had
paintings the paintings were
like really see they don't want us
talking about it
i found the picture by the way i had to
screenshot this just in case you took it
down you guys ready to see this yeah
yeah
okay so let me show you so i like zoomed
in but like you could zoom out and then
you see like she's just cutting her hair
and that's
that should be the focal point right um
look at this [ __ ] p look at this oh
what the [ __ ]
what is happening wait you guys oh might
be too bright but
yeah that's like what's in her bathroom
wait what's the whole picture
what's the whole thing it's weird it is
car rising what what what art was in his
house
just weird no they're just kids like in
weird positions
it was really disgusting like it's
clearly some pictures
it looks like just paintings oh oh
yeah like it was some weird like it's
undeniably like
kids and weird poses and like kind of
like child sacrifice kind of [ __ ] it's
weird
i feel like for politicians they should
have did you guys see it
i'm just tripping out i'm like trying to
make things out but i can't make things
out it's just so
weird it should have trackers on like
all the politicians
if you want to be a politician you have
to have like a device on you
see where you're going i'm not gonna let
that happen but if the politicians of
politicians though
is also involved with whatever
conspiracies we're talking about then
there's no need for trackers
you know what's happening right now like
everyone's printing money in the
government talking about politicians
everyone's getting theirs they're super
low loans whatever
but people still can't like pay off
their credit card bills
so right now we're sponsored by upstart
baby
so yeah like when we were looking when
we're getting our first home it was kind
of hard to
qualify for a loan because i think
unless you have like a
stereotypical w-2 drop like the minute
that you have kind of
like alternative incomes or a different
way of earning
the regular banks and the regular loan
companies they have a hard time
categorizing you and their cookie cutter
loan system so they see you as a risk
they see you as a risk and they just
don't know because they have to do like
like a regular bank got
boats cars student loan you know like
they just have very
specific loans and how they categorize
you it has to fit into that specific
portfolio but when you work with like
loan specialists like a mortgage company
that we end up going with they're able
to look at you and completely reevaluate
another way
and so that's what i like about upstart
is unlike the typical
loan method they go through a different
way of seeing
um if you qualify for loans so for
example they'll go based off your
education
your job history and but you don't even
need a degree or diploma to apply so
uh if you do need a loan like how we did
with um our house but if you need a loan
for a car or whatever
you don't have to go through the
traditionally and with upstart if you do
have
all kinds of credit card debt you need
to consolidate them they can consolidate
into one easy fix
rate payment and if your loan is
approved you can get
in the next business day it's fixed rate
too so you don't have anything and it's
all online and it doesn't affect your
credit because they don't do a hard pull
like they can just check they have a lot
of different ways to kind of see
um if it's approved and accepted you get
the
loan within like the next business day
so over 400 people have used it to pay
off credit cards and meet their goals
it's pretty awesome
yeah so see why upstart has a 4.9 out of
5
rating on trustpilot and hurry up to
upstart.com
record to find out how low your upstart
rate can be
checking out your rate only takes a few
minutes that's upstart.com
record check it out i saw this one tweet
that it was like
the world is in debt 27 trillion dollars
yeah oh i thought the world someone was
i was like oh [ __ ] really the world is
just in debt for that much
who they gotta pay back each other yeah
probably
oh she's in combined debt so who's
owning oh
so it's just everyone owes everyone like
when they say america's in debt right
i'm like rockefeller
i'm wondering yeah like okay so the fed
has the power to print money they're the
ones printing the money and giving us
the money
right so we're indebted to the feds but
we're also indebted to like
japan china saudi arabia a lot of other
countries
i'm like how does this work yeah i don't
know how are we in debt like
they give us money they what do they do
they loan us [ __ ] well
they're like government bonds and stuff
so it's like
they should consolidate they do they
need a hit upside down
is it like a promise like a lot of them
are like
i'm gonna pro in 10 years i feel like
we're gonna be worth this so you give me
this so it's like a pr for a promise for
this money
and then this person immediately takes
that okay so
because they're supposed to hit this in
10 years and i'm going to get this back
in 10 years then they go talk to someone
else
so i'm going to be here in 10 years i'm
gonna sell you a promise so there's just
like
a bunch of like pillows on top of
pillows like just
it's all based off of debt so pillows
and promises and it's just
banks don't make money unless they get
people in debt like a linen store
yeah yeah like banks don't make money
unless they get people in debt so like
the the money supply starts with um the
federal reserve which is a private bank
and then they control how much money
goes out into the public so they can
print it out and they'd be like i'm
gonna print out only 10 million this
or whatever and now the banks different
banks like chase or whatever they get
access to it
and then now they go oh cool we got an
extra
one million dollars or whatever right
what am i gonna do with this oh now i
can uh
give out loans on this million dollars
to
bart because now bart wants to buy a
house and charge interest
but then how do we owe other countries
money if we're the ones printing our own
money is it like
they say hey like like the whole [ __ ]
all the countries get together and then
they go hey
this is the amount of wealth you should
have but i'm gonna give you some so i
give you permission to print x amount of
money
i don't know if they i think each
country has their own like
federal bank that prints their own money
and then so
america will borrow from japan but i
don't i don't know don't quote me on
this i just know that that's how america
works
yeah because that's just weird because i
know that zimbabwe why would i ask
any of you guys because the inflation i
guess because then zimbabwe printed a
[ __ ] ton of money values yeah and then
you got it now it takes the trillions
and broadway dollars to buy an apple
yeah yeah yeah that's all the mexican
peso
pesos used to be i remember i used to be
like i have
old ass money where it's like 100 000
pesos in it probably printed it too much
that's why the whole balance between the
whole economy is so important
because the japan has the opposite
problem where
the com the economy isn't growing
because no one's
taking loans out like no one is like
getting mortgages
no one's buying car loans nothing wow
so that's why um everyone's going to the
city and just renting right
and there's no one actually yeah
property or moving out to the suburbs
anymore
and everyone just saves cash so there's
no
not really because they're good for the
person true for but
when the uh but every year that person
loses money
to uh inflation so then
um i don't get too nerdy and complicated
but
basically in america more than half of
the money
or around half of the money is made just
in financial institution
meaning like in banking and and and
investments right
so it's money making money there's no
actual
like products and value like that being
made
so that's why we're hella rich here yeah
i guess that's one thing that put into
like perspective i was like big gamblers
oh [ __ ] like that actually makes sense
in terms of like inflation where like
when you're like say when i was like 10
and i go to the grocery store
like fruits cost like me like a few
cents
each time you'd buy right because for us
a dollar is always gonna be a dollar
you know like something always cost like
this much but then like fruits and like
basic like breads would cost like two
bucks three bucks an hour cost like
eight bucks you're like
yeah like a can of soda i remember when
i was like 50 cents now it's a dollar
twenty-five dollar fifty or something
it just keeps going up mm-hmm so i'm
like it's actually worth less but
you don't think of it as less you know
yeah
that true damn i don't know i always
think about like the future too and i'm
like
i wonder like where like how
crazy i mean obviously there's a track
record of like how much inflation
like it grows or whatever like how how
it gets so then i don't know i
picked her like being a grandma and
being like oh let's go buy a bottle of
water do you have 25 dollars
that's literally how it's going to be
yeah have you seen prices from like 19
like 60s or 1970s
like a mustang was like 1700 a ford
mustang
uh like a thing of milk was like a
quarter
so like so if people that live from back
then they see our cars
and they i think even probably it
breaking the five
figure mark is crazy yeah even in our
lifetimes as kids
like you could get a soda for like a
quarter
you're kidding joe
you left me you she lit directly at me
when i said that same example
you said what she said no no so she said
that coke thing
then he said no it's happening right now
with the blah blah blah because she
right and then you said it which she
literally go back to what she said
there was a little bit more in between
from that point but yes i literally just
and then she says but now it costs a
dollar 25. oh
[ __ ] so it wasn't 25 cents you okay so
maybe you're gonna maybe yours is
different did you say coke
i said a can of soda so it's different
no no i'm just shocked i just
copyrighted your ass
yes yeah you played your eyes like a
[ __ ]
live live [ __ ] life plagiarism
all the time like with all of us i mean
it's fine
with um like mcdonald's like back in the
day was like 5 cents or 15 cents for a
burger
but i saw us one thing we were like oh
but people are only making like a dollar
per hour i'm like
no they weren't like dollar an hour what
the [ __ ] yeah because they're like oh
that's how things like oh now you make
eight and then it costs like a dollar or
two for like a basic sandwich but i'm
like
that's not how it works like that's how
it worked when in like 1960 maybe
yeah so it's like it's crazy how like
things go up from price and like
obviously like wages go up everything
goes up
what was minimum wage when you guys
started working because for me it was
5.75 5.75 yeah oh it's low
yeah it was 5.75 i think mine was like
eight or something like that
oh really when you started working
you're older than me at 575
yeah i don't remember because i remember
six something yeah me too
yeah and i started working when i was
you were getting exploited
i remember because we're [ __ ] way
older than you and i remember
six dollars hey and they had a whole lot
like
a whole poster and i said like minutes
mexico though that's different
hometown afraid in mexico yeah where do
you live their whole life
that's true i forgot i forgot i was born
and raised in mexico
do